What's going on.
It's a below that's really loud.
That's really fucking loud.
Damn.
What's going on is bill Burke and it's time for the Monday morning podcast for
them.
Monday,
um,
August 21st,
2000.
Jesus,
I've got a cough drop in my mouth.
I got a halls mental lip.
This,
you're not going to want to listen to this are you?
You know what?
I don't have time to start it over again.
I just don't.
You know,
one of the weirdest things ever is when you have to go on a microphone and you
got to fucking halls and your God damn mouth in what?
Like how do you make it go by faster?
Am I supposed to just spit it out?
Is that what you want from me?
All right,
I will.
I don't know where to go here.
You just kind of have to hang on a second.
Just hang on.
Hang on.
Hang Up.
Fuck on this fucking thing out.
Okay.
Bombs that make noise.
It's still a podcast.
As long as I make noise.
All right,
I'm back.
I'm back and I got the energy.
All right.
This is the Monday morning podcast for it's for fucking August 21st,
2017.
You know,
they ain't got no August over there in the Middle East.
You know why they don't believe in Christ.
Do you know,
believe in crash?
God's like,
well,
you know what?
And guess what?
You ain't got no more August.
Right?
That's why I was so mad all the time.
Or summers goes by some fucking fast.
That's true,
man.
You can look it up.
Go look it up on the poo to her over there.
Shit.
Um,
I'm in a great fucking mood.
I got a bunch of shit to do.
As always,
as always.
I'm recording this quarter,
five California time,
um,
on Sunday.
You know,
and I put all this money down on the Red Sox,
right?
You know,
I've been betting the red sox gambling.
Okay.
I'm betting on the red sox.
Two of my friends a Yankee fence,
right?
It's on the edge.
Yeah.
Yap.
Get yet yet Paul is fucking shit.
All rise.
Court's in session.
Can we hear from the bailiff weekend?
His last name is judge Jesus fucking Christ.
How did,
how do people in sports get away with the fucking punch or just basically the
newspaper industry in general?
My God.
Have you reached a verdict?
Yes,
we have.
Your honor.
That was a home run.
You get it.
There is so bad.
Okay.
This sofa,
I wish,
I just wish sweet Caroline was his funny bad is all those Aaron judge punts.
If they could just make it that fun as opposed to just watching a bunch of
people who you know on fucking black Friday,
you have their face pressed up against the wall mart window.
Go ahead.
Right.
How'd that song became part of the tradition?
When the fuck did that happen?
When did it happen?
When will it go away?
You know,
it's bad enough.
They sing,
take me out to the ballgame and never used to do that.
In the seventh thing,
he just stood up and stretched and then Harry Carey did it and it was great.
You know why?
Because he believed it and he was shit faced and he was hanging out the fucking
window and you're like,
is that guy going to fall?
You know,
you know those guys who to boos their whole life,
they get this big round belly and then they got those little pretzel rod sticks.
So when he started getting a lot of that fucking keg out the window,
you know,
that's why they have that net above home plate.
You know what I mean?
Over the fans.
It's,
you know,
that goes back to it has nothing to do with foul balls.
It has to go to,
back in the day there was so many fat alcoholic sticking their head out,
you know,
doing God knows what back then,
I imagine initially,
yeah,
they were just amazed that they weren't on the second floor of a structure
sticking their head out.
Like,
you know,
gee willikers how the hell is this thing?
Okay.
It was probably people underneath me that I can't say right.
Then that gradually morphed into,
Holy Shit,
look how far,
you know,
loud Racor July labral hair right.
Far Right.
If I can fire that morphed into that.
Okay.
And then somewhere in there it was like,
oh my God,
is that a black guy on the field?
You know,
they,
they've always been hanging out the window for years and years and years.
And that's why that net was there.
Everybody thinks it's a protective fence.
It's not to protect the fans.
Back in the day,
everybody wore a hat.
They will fine.
Okay.
The ball wasn't juiced up.
It was the dead ball era.
It go up in the air or you know,
those people were tough back then.
They built railroads with their fucking hands,
you know,
and that's just the Chinese.
Okay,
forget about the people dead fucking built the A,
I dunno what the cotton gin.
All right,
I'm off the fucking rails here.
I don't know what I'm talking about.
All I know is that I'm like,
all right,
I got to get back into baseball.
You know what I mean?
I'm an old man.
It's a slow game and then all of a sudden it gets exciting and then it slows
down again.
Right.
Just like that thing.
As you get older,
every once in a while your heart does something and you're like,
am I going to fucking die here?
Okay,
no,
I'm good.
Right.
That's what baseball is.
And the rest of the time it's just fucking sitting there,
you know,
like waiting for a cough drop to dissolve so you can start your fucking podcast.
That's type of shit.
So anyways,
um,
I decided out of the fucking blue to
Tibet with two of my friends,
both Yankee fence,
right?
Once a gang and giant fan.
The as a Yankee and a Patriot fan figure that one up.
It's one of those Connecticut stories,
right?
You heard of a Bronx tale.
This is the sequel called Connecticut Story and this guy's a Yankee and a
patriots fan.
The most bizarre,
one of the more bizarre combinations of fans I've ever,
I've ever seen.
Um,
so I bet at ball,
you know,
50 bucks each a game.
So they stand to lose 50 again 50 I'm dropping a scene out of picking it up on
the last two series.
So we want two out of three on both of them.
So freckles here is up a hundred bucks,
right?
Is that right?
Let's see.
I was down a hundred then I was even then I was up 100 then it was up 200 then I
was up a hundred now I'm up 200 bucks.
Ooh,
right.
I loved it.
I almost made an extra 50 cause the guy's got,
don't,
I'm telling you right now to fucking Aaron judge,
you know everybody's going to rise and coach going to be in session and they're
going to reach a verdict and now he's going to end up,
I get it.
He's going to hit a home run and I was like,
you fucking cock sucker that guys like all for 50 with guys on base against the
Red Sox to the last couple of weekends.
It course the guys do.
It's Goddamn Paul Bunyan going up there swinging the bat.
And then I thought about,
I was like,
all right,
fuck it.
I'll bet you.
Um,
but I was voice texting and I said,
I'll bet you 50 bucks he doesn't,
but it wrote,
I bet your fixed 50 bucks.
He does it.
And then I didn't hear back from him and I was like,
all right,
you got until midnight tonight to get your bed in or at the,
the offers off the table.
And I,
you said he fell asleep but he was probably sitting on like,
well dude,
I said he was gonna do it.
Why would you?
I said he'd do it for 20 bucks.
Then you said you also think he's going to do it for 50.
I think I weirded him out.
He hasn't called me all day.
So that might be the end of that friendship.
It's funny how that happens,
right?
15 year friendship can end on a voice text that somebody doesn't understand.
Um,
so anyways,
so red sox took the fucking series and you know why they took the series?
Because we spent 200 million fucking dollars and God damn it.
You know,
we better be the fucking Yankees if we're going to spend that kind of money.
I don't know what the,
yeah,
I didn't know what the Yankee spent this year.
I just don't think that most of their own draft picks,
it really doesn't matter.
Right.
Or does it?
I have no idea.
Do you guys see in Spain they set up 800 checkpoints to catch that fucking cunt?
MMM.
Did they catch the guy?
I Dunno.
Yeah.
Desperate to ease public fears of neutralize a terrorist cell responsible for
the deadliest attack in Spain.
Are they gonna neutralize the,
uh,
the terrorist cell?
It was actually going to,
I guess going to be way more deadly,
but the fucking dopes accidentally blew themselves up.
I'm trying to make a bomb.
That's the greatest thing that can happen.
That's my favorite terrorist story when they were building it and then it
fucking blows up.
It's such a fucked up world,
man.
There's just people on both sides that are just out of their fucking minds.
I don't get it.
I just don't get it.
Why can't you just fucking be like me and you know,
battle booze and watch sports and get excited.
Things that don't matter.
Why do you have to have a fucking cause and get all into some invisible fucking
guy that you never fucking met and then everybody around you has to die if they
don't think the way you think.
Okay,
what is it?
There's a tipping point in religion and it's a combination of like,
okay,
you believe too much and you got too much fucking,
I don't know what
you know.
I used to a bit about that.
Do you have like too much power and you get too much into fucking religion?
Like it always goes bad.
You started pressing other fucking people.
You know,
like when my people really get into Jesus white people,
it gets fucking scary.
You know?
Black people get really into Jesus.
Yeah.
Now it's a fucking great service killer band.
That's it.
They're confined white people.
It's an open fucking field.
Whatever the fuck they think they did,
they did.
They just,
they run with it.
No checks and balances.
That's the problem.
So I don't know what goes on with these foreign,
I didn't know what the fuck I'm talking about,
but I don't know what goes on with these people.
What the fuck you can fence somebody that they are less fucking move on the
planet is you're going to walk into a,
to a group of people sitting there watching a show or eating a fucking slice of
pizza and you're going to kill all of them.
And uh,
then God's going to be like,
Hey,
nice going.
Whoo.
Hey Buddy,
I want to talk to you.
You know what?
I would've done that,
but I could dig it.
Thank God you thought to do that.
I Dunno.
So anyways,
so good luck to Spain.
IOP will rattle Kate those clients right out of your fucking beautiful country.
MMM.
Anyways,
I know.
Why do I talk world politics?
Why know why?
Cause it makes you guys feel smarter.
Right?
Hey bill,
maybe next time you bring up Spain,
maybe you could fuck ag.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I'll do what I want.
Oh,
by the way,
I got some,
uh,
I got a giveaway this week for the first thousand people.
All right.
No,
wait a second before you take out you fucking first.
The first thousand people that text a particular phrase to a particular number.
Well,
when some all things,
comedy merchandise.
So they basically stickers.
All right.
Okay.
Texted,
is that what it is yet?
And I'm just letting you know that,
that this is so they can build,
build up their email fucking database and let you guys know what's going on with
this site.
Okay.
So it's fucking transparent.
What we're trying to do here for the price of a sticker.
That's what we're trying to do.
You know,
we're trying to get more social media and all that type of shit because I'm,
we got big shit coming up on all things.
Comedy relaunched the website.
Um,
next month Bert Kreischer has a cooking show on there called something's
burning.
Uh,
I'm going to be doing those road rage fucking videos,
whether you got the fucking camera on me and all of that shit.
And then the person that did whatever they did,
Philippe is spars is going to be doing a home improvement show.
Basically your favorite comics doing the shit that they liked to do,
being funny.
Um,
we got our first stand up special release with Paul Versey.
We've got a bunch of stuff going on and talks of yes,
all kinds of other things,
sports shows and all this type of stuff.
So,
uh,
we're trying to,
got to let you guys know what's going on.
So here's what you do.
If you want a sticker,
if you don't want to do it,
don't fucking do it.
But if you want to do it,
all you need to do is text all capitals,
no space bill burr,
B I l L,
B u r r two four four two two two.
Reggie Jackson,
Doug Flutie,
Derek fucking jar.
Fuck that.
Jerry Remy,
the rem dark.
It was his day today.
I would've said Derek Cheetah,
uh,
44,
22 to two fours,
three twos.
You got it for a sticker and then we'll be bugging you.
Let you know what's going on with all these great shows we have coming up.
You know,
we got Bobby Lee,
we got our Madrigal,
we've got all these fucking people.
All right,
we have our re shift fear.
Um,
all right.
So anyways,
and I gotta be honest with you,
uh,
after these last six games,
red sox,
Yankees,
and having money on the game,
I gotta be honest with you,
after all these years,
seeing Pete rose shouldn't be in the hall of fame that the man was right betting
on baseball.
It makes it better.
It does makes it fuck it makes you care.
You know,
you think October,
baseball is exciting.
Puts your paycheck on a fucking game in August.
All right?
You don't need Joe Buck and all those extra fucking microphones to make that
exciting.
Dude,
am I getting a Camaro with tee tops?
Am I going to be homeless?
You know,
that's the type that's,
that's the type of stakes that you want to raise a,
I'm calling it right now.
Patriots,
giants,
the rubber game this year.
Super Bowl patriots.
Finally fucking win,
right?
No helmet.
Catch no fucking owl Brady to Welker fucking two foot pass.
It goes in complete Noah's Dante,
Samuel drop in the fucking ball.
None of that shit.
We're finally going to beat those concen you know,
Hawaii,
Tom Kaufland.
No.
Tom Conference going to be the difference.
I love what the giants are doing,
I think,
I think they're going to,
you know,
and they got fucking Eli.
He's got ice fucking water in his vates.
All right.
Dead team is looking good.
And I'm telling you that team's looking good cause I've paid attention for about
eight minutes during this preseason and uh,
I've,
I've just been hearing a lot of chatter about weapons being added and in field
goal kickers and all of this type of shit.
And people question in Ely,
right as he sits there and he's dockers and his fucking,
uh,
you know,
I don't know what he's,
he,
oh,
he always looks like he just did the right thing the way he dresses,
right?
Yeah.
The loafers,
the fucking pants,
the sweater,
you know,
just like he dresses the way I should be dressing in my age and he's like
fucking 12 years younger than me and the man gets the fucking job done.
The later this season is,
and forget about in January,
the man is lights out.
Okay.
Telling you,
telling you it's going to be a rematch and we're going to win.
And I that that's the fucking team I want to play.
That is the fucking team I want to play because we got nothing to lose.
They got everything to lose because if they're two window,
they can talk shit for the rest of the fucking time.
I want another shot,
right the fuck to an three.
You know,
I don't give a fuck.
That doesn't make any difference.
But if we get that last one,
but the guy they're moving,
then we can give him shit.
I,
you know what the fuck,
you know it's not,
they,
Sandra dropped the fucking ball and it was a spring,
you know,
whatever.
Whatever we got ya.
Then it's,
then it's over.
Then we got that thing we could say back.
That's what I'm saying.
You know,
cause I've ran through a couple of giants fair.
They're like,
oh they a dog.
You don't fuck away.
Well why don't we want it that just logos at this point,
Eli's probably the only guy left from that 2017 and I bet at least,
I don't know,
three quarters of that.
Both teams are gone since the last one.
That's why I never get into those types of stats.
Go and let these guys will stored glial.
But the,
we'll get blue,
blue,
you'd say it's all different people.
It's all different people wearing the same clothes with better drugs,
better trucks,
better drugs in their system.
Okay.
Just like the drugs that was sent to a particular quarterbacks wife.
Cause she hurt her arm taking cookies out of the oven.
Okay.
It was a complete non story.
However,
had that guy taking a queef worth of air out of a ball,
all of his ranks would have been questioned.
That's how it works.
Okay.
We're taking callers.
Um,
you know what I did today?
I,
you know,
it was funny,
I did so much,
so many fucking positive things today.
So many.
This,
this podcast is not one of them,
but I did so many fucking positive things today.
You know,
and then my wife laugh.
She still had the nerve to be moody
and I don't know about you guys,
but oh,
what the fuck goes on.
I don't know about you.
I don't want to put up with that.
I don't put up with the moodiness.
Okay,
come on.
What do I gotta do here?
What happened?
Fucking thing just died on me here.
Here we go.
Um,
I don't put up with that Moody Shit.
If I did something,
you got me.
I'm sorry.
All right.
I said I'm sorry.
No,
that Moody Shit.
If I do fucking nine things right,
and then the 10 things wrong and then you're going to get all moody with me,
I swear to God.
I swear.
I just,
that's it.
You know what I do?
I go,
hey,
what's going on?
And if she doesn't fucking snap out of it,
then,
then it that I just shut down.
You know?
And then you don't,
you know,
I'm fucking German,
Irish.
She want to play the silence game.
I can do this all fucking do this forever.
Yeah.
All right.
You think there's a lot of silence in master of none.
Let me tell you something right now.
I can do fucking silence.
I don't know why I'm making this motion with my hand.
I grew up with that shit.
Rage,
silence.
You know,
days going by how you dumped console.
Going to stare at the sun tomorrow.
Do yourself a favor.
Just wait for the pictures.
You know what I mean?
Looking at a fucking lunar eclipse.
The solar eclipse,
whatever the fuck's going on here.
It's a lunar eclipse,
right?
Is it the lunar eclipse?
This is the one I learned that when the earth is between the sun and the moon,
the moon turns red
cause it,
it deflects the fucking light or something.
The only reason why I know this is consist,
Shit's happening on Monday and one of the writers in the writer's room knew this
shit.
And then there's the other one with the moon passes in front of this sign.
All my God,
this haven't happened for 37,
38 fucking years.
MMM.
Did you see that little,
not Amin.
Was it a jiff that thing going around about that newscaster that actually really
used to like,
he used to watch him when I was a kid and he said that little,
uh,
that the clubs that I was a little bit with the blah,
blah,
and there's not going to be another one in 38 years and let's hope that when it
did fucking happens on a world that knows nothing but peace,
you know?
And everybody's like,
wow,
okay,
wow.
He said that and then wow.
It's just like,
what do you,
we've never been at peace ever,
ever.
Never will be.
They'll never be world peace than ever.
We were up at the,
the level of,
of violence that would have to occur for there to be peace.
You'd have to be the last person on earth because if there's another person,
there was just two people.
At some point the other person is going to annoy you and then there goes the
peace.
Right.
That's what happened with Adam and eve.
All right.
To tell you what all you people out there that believe we came from fucking the
ocean.
I actually believe in,
in,
in creationism,
whatever the fuck they call it.
All right.
There was two white people that started all of this in.
Somehow we had,
okay.
All the other races out of them.
MMM.
He's two white people,
right.
Adam and eve and they got annoyed with each other,
so she goes for a walk.
Right.
The snake gets in a rare next thing,
you know?
Right.
Yeah.
She goes over and she bites an apple,
which for whatever reason is,
is healthy.
It's a good thing.
It's got fiber in it,
you know?
I don't understand why the man,
the visible guy was upset by that because you know what?
It was an apple with the sugar in it,
like because there was no weed or coke or meth or anything like that,
like apples where I guess the heroin it back then and he said,
let me tell you two little shit.
Something.
All right,
you want to live in this fucking garden of Eden in?
Well,
stay away from the fucking apple tree.
That's it.
She went down and she's probably going to,
hey,
you know,
I'm going to go down and eat one of those fucking apples and and fucking what's
his face?
Whatever it was.
It a brother.
I don't know what went and the none of that fucking,
he's anybody religious.
Listen to this shit.
How the fuck the two white people,
okay,
fuck and create all different races of people.
Forget about that.
How have you just have to f two fucking people and then they bang and then what?
How do you keep it going?
They're kids have to fuck.
Exactly.
You had nothing,
didn't yet.
Their kids have to fuck.
And then their kids kids,
fuck.
Is that how we went from Adam and eve to fucking cavemen
meander talls and when those other fucking people with those slopey foreheads,
you know,
and that,
that fucking Frankenstein brow,
which I kind of have,
is that a,
is that what happened?
Because Adam and eve banged and then their kids had to fair to sit down and say,
children,
you have to fuck one another in order to keep this thing going.
All right.
None of it makes sense.
None of those stories fucking makes sense anymore than the fat guy in the red
fucking suit going down at goddamn chimney.
Okay?
First of all,
if it was fucking true,
all these new homes without fireplaces would not have a Christmas.
What are parents who live in houses without fireplaces?
Say you know up on the house,
top reindeer paws out jumps,
good old Santa clause looking forward,
chimney,
but there isn't one gets back in the say you have no fun.
Go Fuck Yourself,
right?
No guide him toys.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Go to child world.
All right then that's,
that's part of his contract.
You leave cookies and there's a fucking chimney or that's it.
It's over.
That never he,
he has no interest in anybody who's not Christian.
He makes toys for everybody unless they are not Christian.
You know what it is?
It's just everyone.
When we were
tribes and we had these,
we had travs and we just came up with these fucking stories and as it expanded
and everybody started fucking interact in all the holes in our shit,
you know,
when she got that global view,
they'd all fucked up.
All of a sudden the world wasn't flat,
you know,
depending on what basketball play you talked to,
it was route.
He fobs sudden you did find out that it was fucking round.
These people aren't Indians.
They're not from the fuck.
And then add from India and from American Mac.
Right.
The greatest fuck,
oh by the way,
I forgot to say,
you know,
if you go to tech,
I just fucked up.
If you go to tex ethic,
we're not sending a sticker overseas.
By the way,
this is just for Americans only
by Americans.
I mean United States,
America,
maybe Canada,
I know he can't do it cause it's a fucking sticker and then they've got to fill
out forms.
I should've said that earlier.
You know,
I should have done a lot of things in life,
but I got to tell you what,
not telling you guys that you know,
if few texts that fucking number and it's in international and the stickers.com
and that's probably one of my biggest regrets.
Other than the fact the last time I didn't watch an eclipse,
you know,
there was a guy wishing for world peace.
The next time it came around.
And now here we are 38 fucking years later,
38 years later.
Are we any closer?
Okay.
I'm sure somebody said that in the 1940s,
after fucking Hitler and Stalin and all that shit a,
you know,
there was a,
uh,
last night there was a typhoon.
I hope the next time there's a typhoon,
it's a killing innocent people in a peaceful world.
It's never going to happen.
Well,
Jesus build now with that fucking attitude.
The children have to fuck when we return.
Part two of the Adam and Eve story,
the story no one wanted to show you.
Um,
all right.
So anyways,
I've been,
uh,
how many fucking minutes into this pile of Shit podcast and I do and my 25 or 26
minutes people,
26 minutes of some of the most ignorant shit you're ever going to listen to yet
you continue to listen,
you continue to listen.
Um,
all right.
You know what I did?
I,
so I did all this productive shit today and yes,
my wife,
she started pulling the grumpy thing,
right?
Like I was going to wake up this morning of Bardot,
but they'll do it and I was going to go play drums.
All right?
Which I'm still going to do,
but I'm gonna do it tonight.
Okay.
But I could tell she was tired or whatever.
So the advantage [inaudible] that your lady,
Hey Ula has,
is when the kids crying,
they always have the option of the boob.
Bam.
Instant shut it,
right?
Puts the kid to sleep.
They feel comforted and all that type of stuff.
The only way that a man can compete in that arena is you have to either put the
kid in the car and drive around block a few times,
or what I think is better,
you just put the kid in the stroller and you just walk around the block.
Now you're burning some of your dad bod calories.
You know,
your kid gets to look around and see a bunch of stuff.
Fucking acid trip birds flying around,
jets,
cars,
trees,
right?
Everything's amazing to them.
And then eventually they fall asleep.
Um,
so anyways,
I could tell my wife,
my wife was a really sleepy,
so I said,
all right,
you know,
she goes to be really nice if you could just take it for a walk.
Because she was up at,
my wife wasn't,
and I was just like,
all right,
I was going to work out.
I'll go play drums.
You know what?
Fuck it,
I'll do it.
So I did,
went on a nice long walk,
did the whole thing.
We had a great time.
She finally fell asleep after like 20 minutes.
She finally falls asleep and then I walked around like extra,
you know,
take an extra long walk home and you know,
walking further past the house,
coming back up,
come back up.
You know,
my wife's still downstairs.
I can tell she's still sleeping.
We hung out.
We had breakfast together.
Right.
I watched a little of the Jerry Remy,
you know,
Jerry Remy Day at Fenway Park.
Um,
just did all of that.
And then she didn't come upstairs to like fucking,
I dunno,
11 o'clock or something,
something like that.
Since she goes,
all right,
let's go out today.
We said,
we going to go out.
And I'm like,
all right,
let's go out.
Let's go out.
So
she gets the kid ready and everything,
but the fucking shoes,
I tried to put the shoes,
I just can't do it.
I can't do it.
She tries to kick them off.
I start laughing and I can't get them on.
And I finally got one of 'em on and I realized they had it on the wrong foot.
And I was like,
fucking and undo the buckle.
And then I finally got it on right?
And she just kicked it off.
And I just laughed.
I said,
I can't do it.
And I left.
She was like,
really?
And I said,
yeah.
I go,
look,
there's somethings you're better at than I am.
You're just better at this,
right?
So I leave.
She goes,
where are you going?
I said,
I'm gonna go watch the red sox.
She goes,
well,
come down here and watch it.
So I said,
okay.
So then he went upstairs and she told me how her tire pressure was down and uh,
I was trying to remember how to do that cause I knew I had the tire pressure
fucking thing.
You know,
you stick the thing on there so you don't overinflate you don't under inflate,
I'm looking up that we've got a little water bubbler.
We're all out of water.
It's a good opportunity to clean the fucking thing.
I'm looking at Shit like that when I'm up there.
So,
uh,
I didn't go back downstairs and she came upstairs fucking pissed at me because
she spent like whatever the next 15 minutes trying to get ready with my daughter
downstairs for Jane and stand,
there must be a pain in the ass,
but I was up there fucking,
you know.
Yeah,
see,
yeah,
she gets in a mood now.
She's in a mood,
not yelling,
you know,
not flipping out just in a mood.
You know,
they know when they get in the fucking mood,
they get this look on their face,
they stop looking at you and they'd make sure that they keep walking into the
room that you're in.
You know what?
You talked to him and they barely say anything back.
So you do.
You know what?
So you know what?
Come on guys.
Let's,
let's learn something here.
Okay?
So you are aware that she's in a wad.
Oh Jesus.
Somebody is in a mode.
I'm sorry.
Did I do 99 out of a hundred things?
Jesus fucking Christ.
So she's in a fucking mood.
Then I got to go out,
you know,
cause I got my fucked up driveway.
I've got to get my car out of the way.
Bring her fucking car out because you've got to get the fucking air in the
tires.
Oh,
when I'm out door,
you think I'm mother.
I put on a clinic of muttering,
we're going to kit up the Goddamn fucking,
he'll come down and make a buck of his fucking blow up that deck and clean out
the water bubble.
And I got to come home.
Right Henry Hill.
MMM.
So that's it.
And then I go on and be like,
all right,
I will match your mood with an even dumber mood.
So that's it.
So then she starts to,
since then,
I'm in a fucking mood now,
was sure mood put me in a fucking mood.
Now she's sensing that I'm in this fucking mood.
So now all of a sudden,
what does she do?
She starts flipping it around being nice,
right?
And I'm just giving her fucking quick answers.
Like Jerry Lewis rest his soul passed away today,
day Dick Gregory few days ago,
and now Jerry Lewis,
Jerry Lewis,
arguably one of the funniest human beings that ever lived.
Okay.
Ever lived.
He actually spoke at my college graduation and he was phenomenal.
He did the parent student breakfast.
And when he did that,
he was crazy.
Jerry.
And then when he spoke in my college,
he was,
uh,
coming down the aisle.
He was still crazy.
You know,
when they bring people in yet today that didn't,
I'll fucking the fucking with the Dean and all those people come down with
their,
who we have a special colored tassels,
you know,
we're higher than you.
You know,
they come down in their robes while he was coming down and he put his hands on
the shoulder of the person in front of him here when those dumb hats on to when
he put his hands.
And when he walked down,
we just going,
[inaudible] came down and everyone was dying laughing.
But when he went to give the speech,
he was telethon.
Jerry,
it was great.
You got to see the full gamut of the guy.
MMM,
absolutely love that guy.
That guy made me laugh like nobody's business.
So very sad day and a Dick Gregory.
I learned about him obviously being a comedian long time ago.
Read that book Callus on my soul.
Um,
all those stories about him being one of the first black guys to ever work like
white rooms.
You know the playboy mansion in Chicago playing that because what's his face
there?
Hugh Hefner was cool enough to let him play there.
So rest in peace to both of them.
Um,
so anyway,
so now it's all pales in comparison to those two comedy giants.
All right,
so I matched my wife's mood with my mood.
so now she's not done.
Okay,
now she's trying to be nice to get me out of my fucking mood.
Cause then she realizes this is all silent by the way,
this is all body language.
All Kurt little answers,
one of these things.
Now she realizes that,
oh,
I took my mood too far.
I overly made my point,
which justified him now being in his fucking mood,
right?
So then at some point she finally just goes,
Hey,
I you just gonna to like,
she goes,
are you going to be in a bad mood for the rest of the day?
I'm like,
I'm not in a bad mood.
I'm in a great mood.
We have an awesome house.
I tell jokes for a living.
We're going to go get,
we're going to go out today.
I'm in a good mood.
I have the day off.
I am in a good mood.
You on the other hand,
I dunno if she goes,
I'm over it.
I go fight.
Okay.
It's not easy.
It's going to take that talk to me.
I said,
look,
we're going out shopping for kid's shoes.
The second I see kids shoes,
it just puts me in a good mood.
They did.
If they fucking adorable,
those little Jordans,
the little shell toes,
it's a kids' clothes are the cutest fucking things ever.
They're not even for kids.
They're for adults.
See some little sport coat.
You're like,
no.
Yeah,
you can't help it.
So I told her,
I said,
just let me get to the fucking kid sneakers and then that'll put me in a better
fucking mood.
Um,
okay.
Do you know what I saw today?
It's some fucking,
um,
over on labrea they got this,
they got this store.
It's just all these crazy signs and all of this basically junk to shit from
businesses that shut down or a remodeled.
And this guy just has all these fucking sad,
sad.
So I'm walking up and they actually had the old school,
the little Mcdonald's arch with the Arrow that said drive through open 24 hours.
That's what put me in a good mood.
All the,
all the childhood memories.
We were a Mcdonald's family.
We were not a burger king family.
That was a big thing back then.
You know,
nobody talked politics.
She didn't talk fucking religion.
Okay.
You talked about sports and what do you like better?
Coca Pepsi,
coke or Pepsi.
Mcdonald's or Burger King.
Those were the big fucking debates back then.
And um,
okay.
I was out.
We Will Mcdonald's fucking family.
We used to go to this Mcdonald's,
I don't even know where the fuck it was.
It was like in Peabody or north Redding way back in the early seventies.
It was an off,
it was near these railroad tracks.
And I remember there was these fucking seagulls and pigeons and shit and you'd
be eating outside and then throwing them French
fries
and then he got to see a train go by and it was the cool,
this is like pre I pads pretty Fuckin,
you know,
Internet.
There was nothing to do.
Cartoons,
we are,
our UHF antenna was busted.
I could only watch cartoons on Saturday.
So this was a big fucking deal.
I'd always get a cheeseburger is small fry and a chocolate shake.
That's what the fuck I had,
you know,
for a long fucking time passed when it wasn't filling me up.
You know?
But you were afraid of your dad.
It's like,
I'm not gonna ask for a quarter pounder with cheese.
I don't know.
I don't know what this is going to do to the whole dynamic.
Every,
everybody's in a good mood.
I'm not,
I'm not going to try to fucking go up a size here.
That's how Americans got fed.
Once Dad became dad's,
became their kids' friends.
They weren't afraid to fucking supersize their meals.
The last four years of ordering a cheeseburger,
small fry and chocolate Frake shake.
I was still,
I was fucking starving at the end of it.
I ball and my younger brother's cheeseburger like,
you gotta fucking finish that.
Hi,
you little fucking gummy bear.
You know,
you fucking teeth.
I'll eat it.
Um,
so anyways,
I saw that thing today and I was just like,
I would fuck it.
I don't,
I'm,
I'm not into junk.
I'm not in this stuff,
but there's something about that thing.
I just think it's fucking cool to get it fixed up.
It was the,
the,
uh,
the fucking base was all bent and shit,
but to fix that fucking thing up,
I was like,
I just,
I also stick down at the end of my driveway.
Had that thing lit up.
Well,
my class,
like a,
you know,
Cena,
neighbors would hate us.
It's like,
I know the anus,
I wouldn't have a stick it out there if I had like,
you know,
paid some giant fucking house.
Right.
You know,
and there was some sort of,
I dunno what,
you know,
those fucking houses,
those,
those Republicans have them,
you know,
and not saying this is not rich liberals,
but the Republicans live in those states where you can fucking have a house and
then another house on your property.
You know,
you have an old barn,
you know,
when you just let your wife,
your wife gets to fucking house.
Then I'm telling you,
this is my fucking dream,
my dream.
Right.
Um,
you know,
but I mean,
I would love to live.
I can't live out their interracial couple.
I can't go out there and to fucking Nazi land,
you know,
and all these fucking people marching around.
Yeah.
Uh,
but anyways,
I would love to have a fucking old house and one of those states that still has
clean air,
if that even exists.
And he just got a giant fucking what used to be a barn.
And on the bottom you'd have your daily driver,
your classic car,
and like a fucking sick motorcycle.
All right.
And then up top,
I haven't fucking clothes.
They'd be,
I always told you this be drum room,
fucking place to work out.
And the rest of it is just a fucking cigar bar,
you know,
and did some stupid fucking reason I would find it.
Find a place for that Mcdonald's drive through side,
you know?
But the more my wife hated it,
the more it would drive me into the barn.
Um,
anyway,
so let's read some advertising here for this week,
shall we?
Okay.
I always hated at Burger King.
Tried to actually,
I burgers a flame broiled.
Yeah.
And then frozen and driven and a fucking truck across the country.
You know you still,
we showed that in a commercial like this,
sitting there with some fucking open grill back there cooking these fucking
things.
Then I cook it.
These things,
hey.
Oh my God.
No.
Oh [inaudible] me undies.
Burger King or Mickey Days Dodo to me.
Yardies Mejan d Z to bowl fifth.
You please,
but comma,
fat.
Fuck Gang.
Yes.
Dominique's hanging over you.
Tidy fucking whities where's is not?
Would it be nice if they were cradle Lynn?
A nice piece of fucking velvet.
Me undies.
Everybody.
Okay?
Do you want to look good in your underwear and be comfortable?
Yeah,
but that right balance is hard to find.
Don't sacrifice style or comfort.
Checkout me undies,
Dotcom,
man,
and find the best pair of underwear in the world.
Talk about why me undies is the best underwear you will ever own.
Feel free to improvise.
I don't fucking know.
You know why?
Because you don't have to go out to the mall.
They just deliver them right to you.
You feel special,
right?
He ordered enough of them.
You can kind of keep them all together and you've got a giant soft pillow and
you had gets to feel what you're nuts,
Phil,
right?
The big head gets to fill with the little head feels.
How was that?
Me undies will be the most comfortable pair of underwear you will own made from
a sustainably sourced,
naturally thought fabric that is evidently three times softer than cotton.
Jesus stolen.
I was fighting words right there.
Ultimate feel good undies for when you want to feel naked but not be naked for
the fellas,
me undies,
diamonds seen pouch cradles,
uh,
for you.
Cradle for your jewels.
Lacto rhinestone nuts sack.
Do you know he's saying that last week and my mother in law was upstairs and
gives lady,
it gives you stuff,
I'm sorry.
Gives you stuff to support it needs without feeling too tight.
And ladies will love the soft ecofriendly fabric so soft and so touchable covers
it up and lets it breathe.
Ladies,
right now,
me undies has an exclusive offer for just my listeners.
Get 20% off your first pair and free shipping.
And me undies is so sure you'll love the underwear.
They even offer 100% satisfaction guarantee you you order a pair.
If you don't love your first pair,
get a full refund.
This is a no brainer to try 20% off free shipping on 100% satisfaction
guarantee.
What are you waiting for?
To get 20% off free shipping and their 100% satisfaction guaranteed and get the
best and softest side of why are you will ever own.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash birth that's [inaudible] dot com slash bird this
is a limited time offer.
So what are you waiting for?
Start wearing the best underwear of your life.
It changed my life.
It's time to let me and he changed yours.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible] [inaudible] um,
all right.
Dollar Shave Club,
dollar shave club.
Do all his shave club is this mad at choice.
You'll get a great shave at a great price.
Conveniently delivered right to your door.
Uh,
you no longer have to Schlep to the fucking store to buy a cheap disposable
razor that gave you a cheap shave or spend a fortune on a razor with gimmicky
shaving technology.
Yet hell fucking need her right now.
When you use dollar Shave Club's executive razor with it,
doctor Cabi,
theses
labeled giant just glide gently,
gently glides,
giving you a smooth shape.
Dr. Carver shave butter is transparent for a more precise shape,
helps prevent ingrown hairs and fights.
Razor bumps,
in other words,
works on White People's faces and black people's faces.
Make the smarter choice by joining Dollar Shave Club today.
For a limited time,
new members can get their first month for free of the executive razor with a
tube of doctor Kathy cc shape butter for only $5 with free shipping.
After that,
razors are just a few bucks a month.
That's a $15 value for only five bucks.
There's no hidden fees,
no commitments cancel anytime you like.
You can only get to software
exclusively@dollarshaveclubdotcomslashburrthatisdollarshaveclub.com slash burr
oh look who's here.
It's our old friends,
old zip.
Are you hiring?
Do you know where to post your job to find the best candidates?
Talk about the challenges of finding great,
talented and or the importance of finding great talent to a successful business.
Well,
I'll tell you,
I got to tell you,
you know,
when you're looking for somebody,
you got to make sure you get the right person with all those people out there
that are fucking morons.
They would really be great if there was a way to sift through all the smoke
reading more on state.
Go ahead.
Brooder how's Ziprecruiter is different with ZipRecruiter?
You can post your job to 100 plus job sites with just one click.
Then their powerful technology efficiently matches the right people to your job
better than anyone else.
That's why ZipRecruiter is different.
Unlike other job sites.
Sip,
it doesn't depend on candidates finding you.
It finds them.
In fact,
over 80% of jobs posted on Zip.
Yeah.
Okay.
Get a qualified candidate in 24 hours.
No juggling emails or calls to your office.
Simply screen rate and manage candidates all in one place with zip.
Um,
easy to use dashboard.
And right now my listeners can post jobs on zip.
Yeah.
Good.
If I'm running out of ways to do it for free,
that's right.
Free.
Just go to ziprecruiter.com/bar that's ziprecruiter.com/burr one more time.
Hey,
try it for free.
Go to ziprecruiter.com/berg
production hosts,
uh,
production notes.
Hosts are not to mention any competitors,
including,
why would you say all of these fucking places?
Yeah,
I almost read that.
How is ciprocort had been advertising with me this long and they don't really
have stupid.
I am.
If you fucking,
you never saw anchorman.
God Damn it.
Who put that question mark there?
That's me.
I will.
If it's there,
I will read it.
stamps.com everybody stamps.com saves you time and money,
which you can use to grow your business.
I can mail any letter,
any package using just my computer printer in the mail.
Man comes and picks it up.
Avoid the hassle of post office and mail everything from postcards to envelopes
to packages,
domestic or international.
Create your stamps account in minutes online with no equipment to lease and no
long term commitments.
Click print mail,
shoot shit.
And you're done.
Unlike the post office,
stamps.com never closes.
Not Man,
they've got to go better than that.
And like that whore down the street.
I like the horse legs down the street.
stamps.com never closes.
Okay.
Oh wait a minute.
That would mean the other groups where she closes.
I don't like that.
Prude down the street.
I fucked it up.
Anyway.
Print postage for letters or packages at your own convenience.
24 seven keywords.
Descriptors,
descriptions,
I'm supposed to say convenient,
easy,
reliable,
flexible.
Just like a whore.
Right?
She's right down the street.
She's easy.
She's reliable.
Always wants to fucking,
God knows she's flexible.
Um,
call to action are right.
I use stamps.com because why?
Because every once in a while he'd sell fucking posters after my show.
I go out and meet the crowd and God damn it,
I don't want to go to post office.
Okay.
And if my assistant can figure out how to fucking use stamps.com that God
dammit.
So can you,
and right now you too can enjoy the stamps.com servers with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus postage and a digital scale without longterm
commitments.
Go to stamps.com click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburrthatstampsdotcomenterburststamps.com
never go to the post office again.
You know,
I'm one race behind with the Moto GP.
My,
um,
I've really fucking enjoy that.
And I actually,
I think I like it better than Formula One because there's all kinds of passing.
There's no passing in Formula One,
it seems after,
you know,
as far as the first guy,
that's my big complaint.
And then they're like,
oh,
there's all this amazing racing in,
in position four and five and six.
Well,
fucking show that.
Um,
anyways,
let me,
let me just plow ahead here.
Uh,
me undies every,
no,
I already did that.
Let me,
let me ask you,
I'll read the questions for this week.
This is what we're supposed to be doing.
All right.
Okay.
Boyfriend's Facebook.
All this is never good.
All right.
Hi Bill.
Straight to the point,
me and my boyfriend,
we've been together for two years now and we're happy.
Smiley face.
The thing that concerns me is that a few times on his Facebook messenger,
I saw that he is writing on a weekly basis with an ex college colleague of his,
a beautiful young lady.
The thing is that they were close at work back then,
but he quit three months ago and I just don't believe in Male,
female friendships.
I'm talking from experience also when we were wanting,
basically if I,
you know,
if we're having a conversation,
if we're talking eventually we're gonna fuck is what you're saying.
Also when we're watching some videos and stuff on his,
on his phone in the search field,
I saw a list of a few girls names.
Other than that,
he has been great to me and hasn't shown any signs of a man whore yet.
Am I too suspicious or do I have the right to worry?
Thanks and go fuck yourself.
I don't fuck it.
That's not enough.
That's not enough information.
Um,
I wouldn't,
you know this ex colleague that's a beautiful lady.
Yeah.
That's where,
that's the right.
That's fucking weird.
Um,
I dunno about the,
the fucking phone shit.
That's a,
I have no idea.
I have no idea what that's about.
But that,
that thing there,
yeah,
that's definitely a red flag.
You know what I mean?
Like we'll put yourself in his position if you will fucking,
you know,
close with some guy and you left the job three months ago and you're still chat
on Facebook and you know,
here's the thing about women that they can sit there and be like,
oh,
I thought we were just friends.
They seem to be able to get away with that.
But I would always say to the woman I was with them,
it's like,
listen,
can I tell you something?
That guy wants to fuck you.
Okay.
I don't care how much you have in common and how you both like fucking a Rosie
or whatever the fuck it is.
And he really listens to you when you talk.
He wants to fuck you.
Um,
yeah.
So I don't know what you do there because you went on his Facebook and you're
snooping.
So that's one of the things,
you know,
if you're gonna pull that ah ha moment,
you better be right.
Because if you're not,
then they get to play the,
you know,
how dare you snoop,
how dare you fucking snoop on me.
It's just like,
I mean,
don't women have the out?
Why you snooping on me?
Because you have a dick sir.
Okay.
That's why I trust you.
I don't trust your deck.
All right.
Ms. Dot.
[inaudible] too.
So I,
I,
I would bring it up.
I don't know if you bring it up.
I don't have enough information.
That was a really quick and to the point,
which I,
I really appreciate,
but I'm watching some videos and stuff in the search field.
I saw a list of a few girls names.
That's not good either.
I don't fucking know,
but I don't know who the girls are,
but that they are right there that,
that fucking ex colleague think.
I Dunno.
Um,
that seems like a blow job in the future to me.
That's what I,
if I was standing in front of a green screen,
a little meteorologist,
it'd be a fucking Dick floating towards a woman with their mouth open down
south.
All right.
Missed opportunity.
Hey Billy Buckaroo I'm going back to school soon.
Within the next week.
Actually I got an offer a couple of days ago to register for a class,
uh,
this upcoming semester.
That is essentially a paid internship.
It,
it entailed working with a company called Sun Corp.
Why is my stomach growling?
Because I'm on a diet,
um,
called Sun Corp on a software project.
Uh,
if you complete the internship,
you get paid out a couple of hundred dollars,
like two or 300 and of course something worth putting on your resume for job
hunting.
But the thing is that I turned it down.
I didn't think it would mean that much to take it as I don't really need the
money and software engineering majors are for the most part,
guaranteed a job after graduation.
Plus,
I only have one semester left and it's looking like it's going to be pretty
tough and it's looking like it's going to be pretty tough anyway.
All right,
so you've got a constraint in schools.
What's the problem?
He says,
however,
I cannot help feel a bit pissed off at myself for saying no.
It's one of those things that has virtually no negatives to it.
I get to,
I get work experience and money.
What more could I need anyway?
I can't help but see this as a wasted opportunity.
My question to you is,
have you ever been offered an opportunity in your community career that you've
pissed out pussied out on and then have really regretted later and can you offer
me advice on this?
Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
All right.
First of all,
dude,
it's a fucking internship.
It's your last semester.
It's going to be tough.
You know,
you want to fucking go out and party a little bit.
Okay.
It's not the worst thing.
It's not the end of the fucking world and absolutely.
I had,
um,
oh my God.
You mean all kinds of times?
I pussied out early in my career,
I was afraid.
I was afraid to go on stage.
I was afraid of bombing.
I was afraid of the whole fucking thing.
Yeah.
That was a whole bunch of times that I did.
Um,
so what I would do,
I started to do in moments like that,
if my fucking stomach will start,
I gotta eat dinner.
I was good today for lunch.
I had lentil soup and a fucking salad and,
uh,
you know,
I've just been trying,
I've been trying,
I'm laying off the booze.
I don't eat fucking sweets,
you know,
the writers room,
we have fucking Fridays and where we just ordered whatever we want and a
fucking,
they got barbecue and I just,
you know,
that's like at my age,
that's debts like nap food.
It's really like drinking,
like fucking Nyquil assumptions shit.
So I can't do that.
Um,
anyways.
Uh,
let's see.
How would,
how would I answer?
Sorry,
just clicked that fucking elbow.
Hit the button there.
How would I answer this?
I would basically say when I did,
was I,
okay.
I always remember what it felt like when I pussied out that night.
When I put my head down on the pillow,
my big Charlie Brown fucking head,
I put it down on the pillow and I just would always remember like that awful
feeling of of Pussy and out,
you know?
And then I,
so then the next time that moment happened,
I'd be like,
all right,
tonight,
whether I kill,
whether I bombed,
whether just to,
okay,
I'm going to feel way better.
Yeah.
Then if I didn't even try.
So,
but I think you'd be in too hard on your cell phone.
This one.
I mean,
you didn't pussy out,
you just said no.
You seemed like you weighed your options.
If you were too afraid to do it,
then I would say that you post it out.
But I don't think he did.
But,
um,
I don't know if your reasons for doing it were different.
You know,
if there was some sort of fear involved,
uh,
you got to figure out why you did it and then you've got to forgive yourself for
doing it because it's part of like,
you know,
you got to fail to succeed.
Right?
You remember that Michael Jordan commercial,
you know,
all low shots.
[inaudible] missed all those shot.
I failed over and over and over and over and over again.
Then is why I succeed.
There you go.
Same fucking thing.
Um,
all right.
Nose job,
a dear Billy Mozzarella legs.
Um,
wow.
Hello?
Yeah,
my daughter yelling at me in there.
She does this hilarious thing when you're on the phone,
you have it on speaker.
She sees you talking into it and she just starts going,
well,
what do you yell at about,
I can't find a single pass.
You know,
I was telling them that story of how,
you know,
I did all that stuff for you this morning.
Then you got into a mood.
So then I matched your mood with that,
my mood.
And then we had that little game that you play with.
Then you tried to be nice to get me out of my mood.
You know that little thing?
No,
I don't know what you're talking about,
Nia.
I don't know what you're talking about.
What do you want me to say?
No,
I'm saying,
well,
I don't know what he's talking about either.
Nia,
what?
What?
Funny game or you know you're going to mood and then,
then,
then it puts me in a mood.
Then you go,
okay,
maybe I've took my mood too far,
so now I'll be the one to turn it around and then you know me.
You always got to fucking pull me out of the anger.
Mud,
right?
Fine.
Yeah,
sure.
Oh yeah.
Can you tell guys you hear in a voice,
I won't look how beautiful you are.
Hey Buddy.
How you like the computer?
Anything with the screen on it?
You're like,
what are you yelling for?
What?
Cause you got to have my DNA.
Is that what the problem is?
You realize as you grow up every time you screw up,
I'm going to get blamed for that because I'm the screw up in this relationship.
That's right.
Talk to the people.
Tell the people,
what's your feeling?
Huh?
What do you got there?
What are your feelings about global warming?
What should we do?
The baby's senator was surprisingly quiet on some of the biggest issues out
there.
Hey,
how are you liking a,
you love in the Avocados,
aren't you the mushed up Avocados?
You liking him?
She's shy.
She,
she had Mike Fright.
She doesn't know what it is.
It's probably she didn't grab it.
All right,
here we go.
Hey.
Someone's going to ask a question about a nose job.
Some reason my fuck,
oops,
sorry.
Too many Chrissy.
My stomach is growling.
I'm hungry too.
Yeah.
Alright.
Nose job.
Dear Billy Mozzarella.
Like
wait,
like the white,
like the Mozzarella.
I'm a 43 year old married father of two.
Yeah.
He liked it up.
Very happy with my life but could use some advice.
You see I have a Schnoz.
Oh my God.
Do this and your nose is still bugging you at 43.
You're married.
A woman loves you.
You got a couple of kids,
a real honker Oh really?
Big Nose.
A all day.
I got a big nose over here.
Now you want to talk?
Huh?
I been able to get by what?
The successful life coach,
career and marriage.
Um,
but in the back of my mind,
okay.
The back of my mind and whenever I look in the mirror I just can't get over my
nose.
I kind of look like old old joke.
Groucho Marx,
all those old joke.
Groucho Marx with the glasses without glasses.
Um,
now my question is
why are you yelling?
I you,
I gave you the floor and you didn't want to talk and now you're yelling there.
Cutie.
What are you doing?
Huh?
Well,
you say their wrinkles.
My Little Sharpei.
Um,
all right,
where am I?
Yeah.
Now my is being that I've come this far in life and at my age.
Do you think it's super vain or silly to get surgery done?
Money.
Your wife is not an issue.
I just think it's silly of me to really want to do this,
but it's really affecting me where I don't want to look at myself in the mirror
when I shave awe or put on contacts.
Thankfully vice and go yank gauge.
Let's go.
Yay.
You guys were in New York and New York,
the greatest promo ever.
Wheel of fortune,
if you can ever find it.
Um,
when they went to New York,
uh,
I guess where in New York?
Huh?
That was it.
Two second clip.
Um,
here's a thing too.
I,
I actually don't get surgery.
Yeah,
you got to learn to love yourself.
And here's the thing,
when you got a frigging giant nose,
it's really defined your face.
Like people,
that's what you look like.
And then when you shave that thing down,
you're not,
you're not going to look like yourself anymore.
And people are going to be like,
you know,
I bet.
What's wrong with you?
Maybe if I talk quieter,
I bet that the only person that really has issue with your nose as you,
you know,
your wife loves you,
your kids love you.
You got friends,
you're fine.
Uh,
I wouldn't do it.
I would do okay.
You think you think that I haven't looked into,
you know,
whatever Michael Jackson had bleached out of him to put a little bit of that in
me so I can walk wears shorts.
Can I have some of that leftover pigment?
Um,
look,
they always going to have something by yourself that you don't like.
I am a firm believer in just keeping yourself in shape,
yelling over a baby and,
and basically,
uh,
you know,
aging naturally you look way better.
All right.
The liver makes us knows what they're doing.
Uh,
however,
if you're going to go that road road,
I don't know.
You better make sure you find somebody good.
Exactly.
Cause you could end up like that,
that a,
that chick from dirty dancing and I thought it was gorgeous and I loved her
nose.
Yeah.
I love to know.
She looks beautiful.
She died though.
I know she looks,
she looks so cute.
She got the lead in the movie with that knows Barbara Streisand.
Who else has a a very strong knows Sarah Jessica Parker.
Well what or who are the guys that have like strong new Joe Barden,
nick,
Joe Barton.
Joe Bark.
Nick.
Yeah.
That was that lady,
that lady when she made fun of his nose and he said,
you need to lose about 40 pounds before you talk to me,
bitch.
One of the great lines ever.
And then her husband turned around and when she complained,
looked at Joe to one look at Joe and then started yelling at me.
I was like,
you fucking,
oh,
sorry.
Um,
I'm not gonna lie.
That's what I would've done.
I would've picked the smaller guy.
Why?
What do you say when you say pay attention to me?
Man.
Wants to talk to?
Yeah.
Oh,
you talk to me anytime you want.
All right.
As girlfriend's dad for hand in marriage and he denied.
Oh No.
Whoa,
whoa.
Okay.
We got to read this one.
Whoa,
baby.
You gotta be quiet.
Okay.
This one's is riveting.
You got to listen to this one Kiddo.
All right.
Hi Sir.
William Berkeley.
A long
okay.
You know what's so funny is the amount of people that are going to say mean
stuff.
I get it.
She's cute,
but I swear to God if you bring a kid on that poor kid.
Um,
all right,
longtime fan.
Uh,
thank you for all the laughs.
She got me through some hard times and I am thankful that,
all right,
so I'll thank you very much.
Anyways,
I've been dating my current girlfriend for five years.
Come this November,
I'm 25 and she is 24.
I've been thinking about proposing,
so I decided to do an old tradition by asking your father's hand in marriage.
Now that's a,
that's a classy move.
The Dad's like that stuff.
I also asked your mother to be sure,
uh,
to be there as she is very close to both of them.
I took them out to dinner and I told him how much I loved her and how much she
means to me,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Okay.
Once I was done giving my speech,
they just stared at me like I had three heads.
They didn't give me their blessing to marry their baby and went on saying that
they don't think that I get along with all the day.
Don't think that I get along with their siblings well,
and it seemed awkward when we,
the family are together.
All my God.
Oh,
oh.
They said that they felt like I would try to move their daughter away from her
family because of my job and she belongs with her family.
Oh No.
Should I keep dating hoping that something changes or is that the relationship
with their parents can't be repaired or should I just give up on this five year
relationship?
Any help would be greatly appreciated.
Thanks.
I call that sucks.
Yes.
And I can tell you this right now,
marrying into that.
I know that f a nightmare.
That's going to be a nightmare.
Yeah.
You Bet.
I love this girl because I'll tell you it buddy.
Yeah.
That,
uh,
that sounds like those parents are going to screw up.
Did they live on a compound that sounds like the Rayburns and bloodline or
something you're trying to marry into one of those families?
Yeah,
I would walk a,
he's got to talk to his girlfriend about it and be like,
listen,
I wanted us to be a surprise,
but I went out and I asked your parents about getting married because I wanted
to do it the right way and this is what they told me and see what she says like,
and I think you just kind of go from there.
But yeah,
the free masons or something,
you know,
you marry into the family too.
So if you don't get along with them on that level and they're already looking at
you like,
hmm,
sounds like some blue blood.
Yeah.
Don't know.
You know,
the
hedges never need clipping or way she the youngest is she like what I,
I'm just,
I'm curious as to,
did you not see this coming whatsoever?
Because I would find that a little hard to believe.
Um,
but maybe he hadn't spent much time with,
well,
if he didn't see it coming,
that would mean that he's a dope and maybe that's why they don't want him to
marry the kid.
Sky's got no anticipation skills.
He doesn't see what's,
what's the hand in front of his face?
Obviously you know that you don't get along with the siblings.
I feel like that probably wasn't a surprise to you.
It sounds like nobody in the family like shoe,
but that woman,
so she's going to have to then make a decision.
You or them,
which is very romantic for somebody in their 20s but eventually as you start
having kids and stuff,
Christmases and all that are a Gaga.
Oh Dude,
I,
I don't know how much you love her,
but this would be a great thing to walk away from if you could do,
that's five years.
That's a long,
now he's 25 it's a five year.
25 it's Steve shouldn't the first three years he shouldn't have been in a
relationship.
You gotta be a Free Agent College.
Huh?
You got a Yeti at the lay of the land out there.
I mean,
no pun intended over there.
Yeah.
Maybe they think you're just too young or,
well,
no,
they said why they don't approve.
So I think you,
if you are really,
you got to talk to your girl about it.
They don't like,
ah,
yeah,
you got to talk to your girl and see what she says.
Do a favor.
Just dump her.
So then she doesn't know why and then she won't blame her families it because
you're not going to marry into that.
I would leave.
I would leave right now.
Okay.
We're moving on to the next question.
I would leave.
No,
you went in.
He's got a toddler about it.
Oh my twenties I wouldn't have,
cause I would've been smart enough,
but in my forties if your family was just like,
yeah,
you know,
we just don't like it,
dude.
And I would just be like,
all right,
well yeah.
And I agree with that,
but he has to talk to her about it.
That's how you got to tell her what happened.
Can you get the little crazy person here crawling all over me?
She just dropped it.
It's right.
It's right here.
But she's going for the computer.
That lanyard.
So there you go,
buddy.
Here you go.
Okay.
All right.
Let's look at the last one.
Girlfriend's sociopathic mother.
And yet can you give me,
can you give a woman,
because women never writing to this podcast because I'm such an asshole.
Can you give some quick advice here?
This woman went on Facebook.
She's been with this guy for two years.
She said so happy.
He does everything right.
Everything's fine.
But she checked his Facebook.
Why?
Because you guys are happy and everything is going okay.
Why did you check to see how much my check was for today?
Huh?
Oh God,
I can't believe you're just putting me out on front street like that because you
guys snoop,
it's what you do.
Um,
anyways,
I was just curious.
See now you're going to have everybody with the gold digging.
W H are he comments?
That's not why you did it.
Cause because we did a job together and you wanted to see what I made versus,
yeah.
Job Baggage for the family.
Job Back East for the family.
And you wanted to see how much I made first.
What you made.
Obviously I know you're gonna make way more than I make.
Okay.
I was just happened to be there.
I mean they did request me,
but that's a whole other story.
Anyway,
boyfriend's Facebook straight to the
wait,
wait.
Let's go back to the check there.
Why I want to either.
I like watching you twist and the awkwardness that I live in day to day.
Um,
so anyways,
she goes to check the Facebook messenger and she said,
I saw that he is writing on a weekly basis with an ex colleague of his,
a beautiful young lady.
The thing is is that they were close at work back then,
but he quit three months ago.
Okay,
keep going.
That's it.
And what?
I just don't believe in Male,
female friendships.
I'm talking
from experience
bap,
bap.
What'd he say?
Ah.
And what's the question?
What are you doing?
Go back to when we're watching some videos and stuff on his phone and the search
few.
I saw a list of a few girls names.
Other than that,
he's great to me.
Uh,
yeah.
Listen,
this is why you don't go snooping and social media and phone because if you find
something you could,
the thing is if you are looking in that direction,
you're looking for something.
So any little thing,
no matter how innocent is going to get you all fucked up in the head.
So if you're going to go looking for stuff,
you're going to go find stuff.
So either drop it or confessed that you've been a little snoopy snoop and you're
paranoid and you're insecure.
But I think you should just zip it and move on and not look at his,
his social media or his phone.
Anyway.
Wow.
I said she should actually ask them about that.
That guy.
But you're the lady.
I will listen to the lady here.
Well I said it either one you gotta like fess up and be like,
listen,
I've been feeling kind of insecure lately and I went in your Facebook and I saw
that you messenger somebody in.
First of all,
I apologize for invading your privacy because I wouldn't appreciate it if you
did that to me.
But second of all,
since I've done it,
but who is this bitch?
All right.
Girlfriends,
sociopathic.
We Shit.
But you know you're wrong for looking at his Facebook and you know you're
looking at wrong for looking at his phone.
You're wrong.
You're wrong for that.
So just know that.
Girlfriend,
sociopathic mother.
Hey Billy boo.
I can't say that front of that word.
I know,
but still,
uh,
not sure if this is the right place for mm questions,
but I'm in dire need of redheaded.
See Note,
wisdom.
Uh,
so I've been dating this lady for about a year now and her mother is a next
level piece of crap.
Uh,
there are countless examples.
Her SYEP psychopath,
the of a psychopath up.
Wait,
there are countless examples.
Her psychopathic.
Then they always leave out words.
I already read bad enough.
But to trim the fat on the store story,
I'll,
uh,
I'll cite a couple of scenarios.
She has repeatedly asked me whether I use protection whilst banging her
daughter.
And when I responded,
yes,
she goes on to say she has no evidence that I do use protection.
What
would there be evidence?
Where would there be evidence?
No effing clue unless you're banging her house and she's checking the wastepaper
basket.
Don't want her daughter to get pregnant.
I am 21 years old and she is called my mother on multiple occasions to ask to
meet up with her and my girlfriend dad to talk about my girlfriend and I.
My mother is obviously declined.
The invitation is she has continued to grow yet she's continued,
continued to persist.
Other than that,
she is the helicopter parent of the century and calls my girlfriend at least 15
times a day to tell her how to live her life.
I hate this woman with a burning passion,
but I don't know what to do about it with my girlfriend.
My girlfriend is tried to set boundaries with the mother but it has had no luck.
We'll just don't answer the phone.
I think about the future and I never want to see this woman again,
let alone have her be in the law being in law or the grandparent to my children.
I'd love to hear what you,
thanks.
Thanks.
And go f yourself.
Yeah,
I mean this word,
this guy's thinking at 21 that other guy should've been thinking at 25 like
you're going to marry into that.
So I mean you're young enough where you know,
I'm sure
your girlfriend's only a few years out of the house,
but she needs to just don't answer the phone.
Yeah,
she just doesn't,
she's worrying.
Her daughter's too young and it's gonna like leave her forever and all that
stuff.
She was like attached.
She's like,
I don't think she's a sociopath.
Who knows whose kid who,
neither one of us know this woman.
Neither one of us know this woman.
We don't have enough information,
but we're going.
We have to go off of what people write.
So when us,
that's the only way that we can do,
we have to let go all in.
It's like when you watch a TV show,
you're just going to watch it.
You can't be like,
well,
that would never happen if Babb have a bath.
You just got to like
Dr [inaudible].
I'm not pretending to like solve somebody's problems within 22 minutes.
Yo need to stop
punching her in the face and stop doing math.
Okay.
When we return.
Yeah.
You got to talk to your girl.
Your obviously your girlfriend knows,
but yeah,
you just got to ignore the mother.
Yeah,
just ignore.
But yeah,
I know a piece.
If she's,
if she's calling like 15 times a day and she's asking about their sex life and
she's calling their parents,
that's really,
that's crossing the line.
Shove it off to buffalo.
Yeah.
You got to respect your kids.
Uh,
boundaries like their own personal space.
You can't be calling somebody's boyfriend asking them if they're using
protection.
Ask your daughter if she's on the pill and if she's not getting her some
otherwise,
what are you calling me for a lady?
Yeah.
That's weird.
Ah,
Jesus gets you pause out of my pants here,
lady.
All right,
that is the podcast.
For this week.
Congratulations to me.
But when it all this money on the red sock socks,
making baseball exciting by gambling,
there's your lesson.
You are so adorable and all you do is smile.
A happy baby.
Be In a good mood all day.
Look at you.
She's getting mobile,
everybody and any things that she sees,
she wants to get our hands on that she gets her hands on and then she wants to
go to something else and I'm going to tell you something right now.
Nobody can flip over faster than this one.
By the way.
Shout out to Rick Flair.
I'm hoping he's doing better.
I heard that he's a recovering and I'm looking forward to seeing them doing the
flare chop.
The flare struck,
the flare flop.
All of it.
Absolute legend.
Um,
we already lost one of the funniest guys of all time.
Jerry Lewis.
Yup.
Dick Gregory.
Do you realize how many stories went with those two guys just today and forget
about Don Rickles.
That just closes a porthole too.
Like Sinatra,
the whole rat pack,
Redd Foxx,
Richard Pryor,
all of that.
That porthole just closed.
So I hope somebody made a documentary.
All right.
That's the podcast,
everybody,
or a day type on my dad's save today on the couch.
She was a fiery,
the face plant right off.
And I just like,
like lightening quick.
Nia lightening quick like a freckled pasty Cobra.
I was able to grab her.
All right.
That's it.
She's turning.
She's going for the,
uh,
the mixer here.
All right,
you guys.
I will,
I'll check in union Thursday instead of Nice,
because the kids here.
All right.
See?
Yeah,
right.